okay so donald trump had another one of
these rallies that he has restarted over
the fourth of july weekend
i covered it live and tomorrow actually
hopefully later today i'm going to lay
out what i think
uh will happen if donald trump does
indeed run
in 2024 i happen to think that joe and
kamala
are in real trouble if trump runs in 24
i know that there are some in the
audience who disagree with me
and some that vehemently vehemently do
agree
we'll get to that later but in terms of
the rallies themselves
they're truly horrifying i mean every
time i cover one of these rallies i get
dozens of emails especially from foreign
viewers saying
david what is happening in the united
states these rallies
are dangerous this one was in florida
trump admitting to crimes during them by
the way we'll get to that
uh of course telling completely
corrosive easily debunkable lies about
american democracy and the crowd it it's
it's not even notable to say the crowd
believes it
there's not even the possibility that
the crowd might question
anything they're told at these rallies
and that's very scary
does the crowd have what we would call
an illness
i'm increasingly unsure what we even
call
what these folks are suffering from so
let's just start with trump confessing
to crimes during the speech
trump's business his organization and
trump's cfo alan weiss
weisselberg have been indicted part of
these charges
uh relate to allegedly avoiding taxes by
having donald trump
directly pay for stuff for his cfo
over a 15-year period tons of stuff tons
of money
and trump admits even if only to part of
the stuff
saying not paying taxes on your company
car
or your grandkids education the
allegation is trump would directly pay
for weisselberg's grandkids educations
which really should be income
weisselberg pays tax on and he's accused
of not paying tax on that
that's what they're accused of and
trump's admitting it here take a look at
this
and yet they go after good hard-working
people
for not paying taxes on a company car
company you didn't pay tax on the car
or a company apartment you used an
apartment because
you need an apartment because you have
to travel too far where your house says
you didn't pay tax or education for your
grandchildren
i don't even know do you have to but
does anybody know the answer to that
stuff
okay so trump admitting to it and the
crowd
barely has any idea what trump is even
talking about but
trump is confessing to the crimes that
they have been charged with
in this case this actually helps him
and his followers if he just admits to
it in public this has
been a strategy for a long time you
admit to it in public
trump says it definitely shouldn't be
illegal the fact that there's a law
against this is
me being a victim of something and his
followers just get on his side
a hundred and ten percent even though
he's admitting to crimes
when others say listen okay
drugs fine but that really shouldn't be
a crime these law and order right winger
say
but it is and law and order means if
something's a crime you have to be
punished for it
when trump says is this stuff even a
crime
it shouldn't be a crime then they're
with him a hundred percent
and trump even pointing out during this
speech the strategy
that he uses if you keep repeating lies
to your followers
your followers will start to believe
them trump talks about it
as if it's uh applicable to democrats
but it's actually exactly what he does
take a look at this
all of a sudden they said today i heard
and there's a word disinformation is
called this
if you say it enough and keep saying it
just keep saying they'll start to
believe you we can't let that happen
because now they're saying the
republicans
wanted to to fund the police i said you
know
this is why half or more of trump's
followers
still to this day believe that he won
the 2020 election because trump and
others keep repeating it
trump then paints himself as a victim if
you can believe it
and he brings up hillary clinton yeah
it's 2021 we're halfway through 2021
he's bringing up hillary clinton stuff
from 2015 and earlier look at this
from ukraine from china
they didn't go after hillary clinton and
her foundation they didn't touch her
they leave democrats alone no matter how
bad they are
but they've mobilized every power of
government
to come after me my family my wonderful
employees
and my company solely because of
politics so trump as usual
the biggest victim of anybody you'll see
later in the show his children
also painting themselves as just the
perpetual endless victims
now then it goes totally off the rails
trump gets back
on the statues stuff and he claims
without any evidence
that democrats want to replace the
jefferson memorial
with a statue of al sharpton which is
baseless first of all
it strikes me as probably racist in some
way
although i'm i'm trying to figure out
exactly all of the ways in which it is
take a look at this clip they want to
take the statue
of thomas jefferson out and replace it
with somebody
by the way let me tell you you're not
going to be happy with the person they
want to replace him with
ladies and gentlemen thomas jefferson is
being removed from the jefferson
memorial
and being replaced with the reverend al
sharpton
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think so so it's also really
stupid i mean i
i wouldn't want an al sharpton statue
replacing the jefferson memorial and i'm
on the left so it's just like
layers upon layers of dumb gas lighting
and then of course no trump rally is
complete without the slurring part of
the evening i won't spend a lot of time
on this
the speech went nearly two hours clearly
way too long
for trump and as the sweat poured the
slurring ramped up
here's trump saying that our ancestors
crust they crust fascism
take a look our ancestors
cross just absolutely crushed
fascism beneath the weight so an
absolutely
absurd event these apparently are going
to continue
i think that this is part of trump's
plan
to build himself up and build up his
influence going into 2022 and
because you know normally i won't talk
about an election that's not the next
one
but i'm actually gonna break my own rule
later on in today's show
because what trump is doing now is as
much about 2024 as it is about 2022 and
you really can't talk about one without
talking about the other so i'm going to
talk about that a little bit later
but next what i want to go to is to show
you
some interviews with trump supporters
that went to this rally in sarasota
florida
which is arguably even scarier than than
the things trump said himself so let's
get to that next
do not forget that one of the best ways
to support the david pakman show is by
supporting our awesome sponsors
and today one of those sponsors is
sheath underwear
the weather is warming up it's hotter
it's stickier out there and
unfortunately for many of us that comes
with a lot of sticking and rubbing and
chafing
with traditional underwear that is what
sheath underwear
has solved sheath has developed unique
boxer briefs
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front
preventing skin on skin contact that
means everything stays separate dry cool
and comfortable
with sheath underwear there is no more
sweating no more chafing
no more readjusting it's great sheath
underwear is giving the david pakman
show audience
20 off when you go to sheath
underwear.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
give sheath underwear a try
my experience has been great i believe
yours will be as well
you can find the link underneath this
video and do not forget to use that
promo code
pacman for 20 off